researchers have been covered evidence
of a Neolithic skull cult at an
important archaeological site in
southeastern Turkey they found skull
fragments with unique markings buried
among the earliest known examples of
monumental buildings sometimes called
the world's first temples since there
were markings on fragments from three
different skulls and they were found in
the context of the gobekli tepe site for
which a clear ritual component is
proposed researchers believe that these
fragments could be evidence of the
presence of a skull cult a skull cult
means people were modifying decorating
and displaying skulls in a ritual
context other decorated skulls been
found at other Neolithic sites in the
Middle East but this is the first such
find at Quebec Lea tempeh here the
bodies were buried the skulls
occasionally exhumed and stripped of any
remaining flesh subsequently skulls
could be decorated with paint or facial
features remodeled in clay analysis of
the new fragments revealed cut marks in
the skulls left over from the defleshing
process as well as deep grooves made
with Flint tools and puncture holes
these incisions and holes are a type of
skull modification that hasn't been seen
before in this region and suggests that
the skulls are strung up as decoration
it's too soon to tell whether these
skulls were marked as a way to honor
ancestors or punish fallen enemies
researchers will be back this fall to
look for more clues to the rituals more
skulls and the missing skeletons
[Music]